Moore's Law is sort of saturating as
resources become more and more capable
they become more and more demanded a
similar thing can happen with with AGI
and I think it could be a because the
utility but B because of the lawyers I
think that we are in the process of
evolving not just one but two new
intelligences can you have truly
artificial and intelligent you know gaii
whatever you want to call it AGI without
pain are we as humans a series of
algorithms I think we have to say there
is no evidence right now but there is
huge philosophical religious
implications absolutely I think in a way
the most beneficial use May redound to
us in that it is a mirror I love when
you geek out like that
everybody Welcome to moonshots and
mindsets about to dive into a podcast
with a dear friend Brian Keating an
astrophysicist a cosmologist and
inventor he's a professor of physics at
UC San Diego and he's also the executive
director of the Arthur C Clarke Center
for human imagination he's written a
number of books including losing the
Nobel Prize and into the impossible and
we're gonna have fun you're gonna hear a
conversation around a couple different
subjects I'd love to hear your thoughts
on them the first is is there
intelligent life out there in the
universe is there intelligent
technological life Brian takes the
position that there is not and I take
the position that there is I'd love to
hear what you think after we share that
debate we're talking about things like
Arthur C Clarke had a chance to meet him
his influence on science on technology
are we alone in the universe and are we
living in a simulation we're going to
dive deep into artificial general
intelligence is it a good or bad thing
is it something that's going to
transform life in a positive way or
negative should we be going to Mars or
living in O'Neill colonies orbiting the
Sun ultimately this is a conversation
for the nine-year-old kid in you who's
excited about the future of humanity in
Space the discovery of intelligent life
and really a conversation around the
potential for human imagination all
right let's dive in with Dr Brian
Keating hey Brian
yeah you're my uh first big name guest
on the into the impossible podcast when
I started it in Earnest in 2020. I
started in in 2018 with Freeman Dyson as
my first guest uh but we didn't record
video and I I really didn't amp it up
until uh until you came on and and gave
me the uh the patented diamandas bump
well my pleasure and pleasure to have
you uh reciprocate here and to talk
about subjects that I uh I dream about
and I love you know I've gone hard over
on longevity but the nine-year-old Kid
in Me is still very much all a space
cadet for sure
likewise and of course you've been such
a generous and friendly supporter of the
Arthur C Clark Center for human
imagination where I am the associate
director now uh and it's almost uh 11
years old I think and that is amazing I
remember I remember when you and Eric
very started talking about the this and
you know I've been a huge Arthur C
Clarke fan for ever you know I pride
myself in having known him earlier in my
life and uh love his stories love his
work uh and anything I could do to
perpetuate his vision uh and his ability
to foretell the future was something I
wanted to do yeah there's so few people
like him uh around and historically
speaking both for his scientific you
know kind of Science Fiction output but
also his quips you know the name of my
podcast into the impossible comes from a
series of questions that I'll ask you
later on as I ask all my esteemed guests
when they come on my podcast but he said
of course the only way to know the
limits of the possible is to go beyond
them into the impossible he also said
another thing which I like to use at
Faculty Club meetings which is the you
know for every expert there's an equal
and opposite expert so I like to lay
that on my department chair there's lots
of Great Clips right and it's like you
know uh in the beginning uh crazy you
know when something's uh first presented
it's a crazy idea and then the second
stage it's you know well it might work
but it's not worth doing and in the
third stage of a revolutionary idea is
you know people say I told you that was
a great idea all along
idea yeah
you know I'd love to share if you don't
mind uh my memories of him because yeah
I missed him yeah I met him when I was
21 years old I was at MIT as an
undergrad or as 20. and uh Todd Hawley
Bob Richards uh David Webb and I went to
the United Nations conference on the
peaceful uses of outer space it's the
first international trip I had done my
own and it was a big deal I was um uh
chairman of students with exploration
and development of space seds at the
time and it was incredible when I went
there and there was this giant
conference in the middle of Vienna on
space and all this was the height of the
Cold War right the Reagan Star Wars
initiative is going on and I walk in to
this Hall
and there is Arthur C Clarke with a
group of people around him holding court
and uh I didn't actually know who he was
I had read childhood's end in high
school but that was it I'd heard of 2001
and seen the movie but never connected
with him and uh so Bob Richards and Todd
Holly goes oh my God it's Arthur C
Clarke let's go talk to him and so we go
and uh we stand around and we start a
conversation with him in the middle of
the conversation he just leaves he just
takes off and I'm like how rude that I'm
really pissed and so we end up going to
hear his presentation and he's on stage
you know in this uh U.N like Forum you
know up in the Deus and I I lean over to
Todd and Bob and I say he's going to
take us out to dinner because he was
really rude I was I was just so
convicted about uh about the headset
conviction and so afterwards I go up and
uh
I'm I find him and I I say you know you
know Mr Clark I would love if my
colleagues and I could take you out to
dinner tonight
and uh he he ends up saying yes we go
out to dinner of course he pays I win my
bet that he would take us out to dinner
and it turns out he has a hearing aid he
just thought we stopped talking but he
ended up becoming the uh the chair of
our Advisory board at students for
exploration development of space and we
visited him a number of times in Sri
Lanka and the guy just had an incredible
View and vision I just saw a post that
Elon made recently sharing uh his
Arthur's sort of prediction on computers
and on AI and it's still as relevant
today you know basically that we're
birthing a new species on this planet
yeah and of course you know this podcast
game that you and I are so deeply
invested in I think it gives us both a a
really surprising amount of joy that we
get to talk to people outside of work
and at least for me when I get to
there's people I have to talk to Peter
and then there's people want to talk to
you right so you're one of the latter
when I when you uh we always open the um
the show our show with his actual voice
saying open the pod bay doors Hal uh
from 2001 A Space Odyssey and of course
the iPod got its name from the pod bay
in uh and Arthur C Clarke's 2001 the
Space Odyssey so very closely related a
direct through line from podcasting to
Sir Arthur C Clarke that I don't think
most people appreciate yeah well a lot
uh emanates from his uh his storytelling
um and uh his his story is his uh books
are still as relevant today as they
always have been what do you think he'd
make of of of the kind of you know kind
of Singularity that seems to be
approaching to quote your good friend
Kurzweil uh with with AI I mean I've
listened to a lot of your uh your
moonshots podcast lately and and they've
rightfully been you know I think you are
you know perhaps the go-to source for
for some of these uh great conversations
with leaders like like Samir Khan and
and and other folks that you've talked
to and of course you've talked
intimately with Elon and he's you're the
only person Peter I think that Elon
never you know responds to uh
sarcastically to kind of you know he
says like I love your I love your
optimism Peter and I think if he said
that to anyone else they'd be like what
the hell did he did I do to deserve his
wrath but anyway uh what do you think
Arthur would think about uh about you
know things like chat GPT and I'm using
it for teaching I'm using it for basic
type setting and research functions and
coding uh it's really blown me away on
the other hand it needs more supervision
than my you know my twins do and they're
on a daily basis so as a father of twins
you know the the pleasures of twins but
um but tell me Peter what do you think
Arthur would think about I mean if you
could invoke his his uh natural
intelligence I think he would view
Humanity birthing a new species
I think that we are in the process of of
evolving not just one but two new
intelligences one is AI on its own
whatever you want to call it you know
eventually AGI and call it any name you
want but it's an intelligence that is
different from ours it's not structured
like our uh cortical columns in our
neocortex and doesn't work the same but
there is a level of intelligence and
growing intelligence there and we're
also giving birth to a hybrid right a
human AI hybrid there will be the those
humans who choose not to go on the
journey those that merge with technology
and those in in AI on its own I think
that's fascinating and I I you know one
of the questions I've been pondering and
you're the right person to talk to about
it Brian is is this the inevitable
process that goes on in the universe is
do does does it have start with
biological life always and then biology
leads to uh silicon or you know pick
your favorite substrate materials yeah I
mean I've been uh wanting to talk to you
about that as well first of all you said
something I think recently about you
know kind of the pathway forward and how
um the age of abundance has taken us
away from you know using whale oil and
and so forth uh as I point out in my
first book losing the Nobel Prize that
was really obviated and superseded by
the development of petroleum and and
that was really the purview of Alfred
Nobel and and the construction and
Mining operations that Dynamite enabled
but um but I wonder you know if you if
you think about it um I'll just put it
out there the the development of a solar
panel in some ways might require whales
you know in other words there might be
some inevitability that you have to go
through this this Pathway to get to
kardashev you know lager you know 10 to
the minus three or whatever we are uh
Dyson you know a level that we're not
even approaching so I love you like that
yeah it's fun to get paid to do that
right
um and then on the other hand you know
so there is a sort of inevitability
towards the the
um predecessor primitive Technologies
you know I joked about well we needed
dinosaurs to get to uh to get to you
know petroleum right and people oh it's
not dinosaurs it's pretty okay it's
dinosaur life or it's it's ancient uh
you know biological hydrocarbons right
hydrocarbons so does is that is that a
necessary step is that is that it's an
efficient step I think they're neat I
think there's no large jumps in the
words our ability to uh need electrons
uh would not have happened had we not
had oil
right in other words we weren't we
didn't create large uh uh dynamos
burning whale oil whale oil gave us
light and gave us the desire for more
light to read and to function during the
nights but then it was only higher
energy density petroleum
coal petroleum other things that allowed
us to drive these large dynamos that
created electrons and then we switched
over to an electron driven Tech
ecosystem and then we said okay how else
can we get more efficient electrons and
that came from solar and soon Fusion or
micro nukes and so I think that is a
required predecessor yeah and you look
at it and you see things like you know
computer was not designed by a computer
you know the first programming language
chat GPT is programmed on a very
Advanced you know programming substrate
which itself is predecessors going all
the way back to Assembly Language but
but that you know is even not the first
First Step so this kind of first start
problem or cold start problem I think is
an interesting one and and the other
thing I like to point out and I'll pose
this to you do you know what uh Albert
Einstein called his happiest thought
Peter did you you've experienced I think
I've heard this but you've experienced
this with Stephen Hawking so I'll leave
it at that I'll jog your memory well if
you experience with Stephen Hawking I
mean it was it was his Joy of of being
in weightlessness his Joy of being
exactly
what was Einstein's greatest thought so
his great his most happy thought he
called this my most joyous thought was
that an observer in free fall will
experience no gravitational field this
led to the notion of the the unsigned
equivalence principle which led to
general relativity now I ask you Peter
is it possible a for an artificial a i a
e an artificial intelligent Albert
Einstein to a experience Joy or B
somehow manifest what Free Fall
viscerally feels like in other words the
greatest culmination and one of my late
colleagues Professor hanspar used to
call general relativity or we call it gr
as the greatest accomplishment of
Western Civilization not not just a
mathematical physics but it was a
culminate because it took the work of
collaboration and the abundant resources
the excess Capital left over to allow
people to do stuff the lack of wars and
so forth and Communications and math so
he called that the greatest Pinnacle so
can a computer Peter feel the sensation
that's going to be the uh the question
ultimately the question you're you're
poking at which I think about a lot and
I ask many people is uh will and let's
just call it AI versus AGI but what is
it that humans can do that AI cannot
right is there anything that that AI
cannot accomplish uh one of the
conversations I had recently on
abundance on the stage at a360 I need to
get you there next year by the way is
was with Imad moustak who is the head of
stability AI one of the top um
generative AI companies and he was
saying the number one
uh thing that he selects for in his
companies and his employees and his
Partners his passion and that that idea
of passion May in fact be the most
important last last stand for humans
um and that passion falls into emotions
can can computers emulate love and uh
and passion and emotions I I I'm sure
they will be able to emulate it uh will
they be able to exude it where when you
as a human are on the other side of it
you truly feel their passion that's
going to be interesting yeah
how do you feel about that I'm an AI you
know kind of uh minimalist in some sense
I'm also an artificial I'm sorry I'm an
alien life minimalist too I don't
believe there are any intelligent life
forms out there who's gonna have a great
argument about that one okay I believe
that if there is life in the universe it
originated from Earth uh uh and um and I
we can sort of talk about some of the
ideas behind why I think that way it's
controversial and we will
and even though I'm an astrophysicist
I'm not speaking on behalf of the field
that I am directly involved in and so
like any physicist that frees me up to
speculate wildly but uh but the best
part about it is I don't believe it what
I'm saying can be falsified at least in
the near terms so we could make these
predictions and and I wouldn't have to
pay your famous Wagers of of sin if I'm
wrong but Nicholas taleb you know in
cheerful fashion as he's known to do put
something out you know that these tests
that are passed by by the chat um AI
engines uh the the fact that their past
has more about the test than it does
about the uh the advanced ability of AI
and I sort of agree with that statement
as curmudgeonly as he normally is uh
that you know I mean I think a lot of
what we're seeing is a you know it's
it's sort of a mirror what we're putting
into it like a like a perfect mirror is
reflective of who we are and it can do
things that we can do but I've often
wondered you know can you have uh can
you have truly artificial and
intelligent you know gai whatever you
want to call it AGI without pain and you
know pain is different than love we you
talked about you know can they love a
few minutes ago I I think it's it's
interesting to know can they feel pain
just like Bentham used to say about the
you know being cruel to animals and and
so forth that the question was not you
know do they do they you know have
consciousnesses can they feel pain pain
and you know we could talk about that
some other time you've written a lot
about the the prospects for artificial
meat and and so forth in the future but
um and and currently right now I I've
talked a lot about it but let's just
let's go there one second because I do
think you can I mean what what is pain
pain is a you know a negative uh uh
across the board uh negative impulse
um as a result of uh of an action or a
thought or an activity and can you
create a pleasure pain Matrix for a
computer
um that has implications I mean one of
the things
um uh you know Palmer lucky the founder
of oculus uh had another conversation
with him at a360 this year and and he
created a a a version of a VR headset
that had explosive bolts on it that if
you died in the game it would take out
your prefrontal cortex right and you'd
be dead and and he did it just for fun
more as a piece of artwork than anything
else just to say you know what would it
be like if living in the virtual world
had real consequences like life and
death
um could you imagine creating that uh
for an AI as well where uh consequences
of doing something that caused pain
reduced
your resources access to power or memory
or compute blew a capacitor and would
shut you down at the end you know that
there would be death and so forth I
believe you could you could create that
and and uh in in the algorithms that
govern government that I mean we are one
of the questions fundamentally is are we
as humans a very robust complex series
of algorithms whether we've got uh
whether we've got Quantum compute in our
in our microfibrils of our of our
neurons or whether we're something else
I just finished uh reading a book called
thousand brains that looks at you know a
theory for for intelligence in the mind
um I think you can I think you can
program love and and in pain into
computers going back to your original
point though Brian
um today's
AI is today's generative uh ai's open Ai
and chat GPT and the like
are all reflections of human
data right I mean the large language
models simply reflect what we've put out
into the world
um and so it reflects us it doesn't
reflect it reflects extrapolations of
what we've said in interpolations of
what we've said but it still reflects us
and I think it is exactly right Peter I
think I think in a way the most
beneficial use May re down to us in that
it is a mirror so you and I can nerd out
about a great many topics from you know
parenting twins to you know writing
books uh to space to Arthur C Clarke but
one of our shared passions is Aviation
and we both fly our own little planes
around and so forth
um so you I recall using Microsoft
flight simulator in 1985 I I it was back
when I knew all the names of all the
astronauts that have ever got come
before
in in through the towers in Chicago and
and champagne and then you'd fly right
through the towers exactly um and since
then we've moved up you and I moved up
to larger and larger aircraft you know
rather than the Piper Archer that they
used to feature in my msfs now we were
flying around then and we'd go
underneath the Golden Gate Bridge and so
forth or at least I would and and I
would even do that in some of the more
advanced simulators including the moving
simulators and if you've ever been in
one of those it's really you come out
you're nauseous a little bit you really
feel and it's not like it's a faithful
representation of the graphic capability
of a modern you know a PC flight
simulator I mean the modern flight
simulator gives so much but the addition
of motion gives so much more reality to
it now building on what polymer said and
I think he is a great visioneering uh he
imagine if in the flight simulator when
you tried to go through you know uh the
Golden Gate Bridge underpass or between
the support cables uh and you hit one of
them you got an electric shock you know
right to the the sphincter region or
wherever you could you could design this
or you had on your helmet you know like
you got you got a little you know Joy
buzzer on you it would it would in
addition to the level up you know
reality of it it would make you more I
believe it would make you more uh
capable to perceive risks and I think
pre-gaming faster and so another way
that I think that AI can help but I
believe it's being hindered I believe
this is true that Moore's Law is sort of
saturating uh there we can leave aside
the GPU kind of use of it but there's
there's some principle and I forget the
name of it you probably know the name of
it as resources become more and more
capable they become more and more
demanded just like the old saying if you
want something if you want something
done right ask somebody who's too busy
to do it right because they have so many
people asking them because they're so
capable now I've seen the saturation on
the upper end although it's classified
information we use Department of energy
computers at Lawrence Berkeley National
Laboratory and in that laboratory they
have you know the Pearl Mudder machine
and we don't even know how fast these
machines are Peter but we know that both
our allocations are dropping every year
to analyze Cosmic microwave background
radiation data that's my that's my area
of expertise and also the you know the
net throughput in these high throughput
and high performance Computing systems
because of their utility or so in such
high demand that actually the Moore's
Law performance where it really counts
the actual end use how many actual
papers are being written say or how many
new uh data sets are analyzed is
actually saturating and I think a
similar thing can happen with with AGI
and I think it could be a because the
utility but B because of the lawyers and
let me let me just bring up this fact so
I talked to Eric tole Paul
um you know a very famous physician down
here at the Scripps Research Institute
you know I was involved in in brolios
with the covid-19 we're not going to
talk about that but um but he has booked
you know the the patient will see you
now and then he has you know a book
about Ai and so forth and data in
medicine now one of the most important
barriers that he claims is that you know
today we see people it used to be the
doctor was sitting there you know
writing down on his notepad or whatever
you guys used to use when you were back
in medical school uh and then the
patient was like looking up at the
ceiling and they weren't looking at each
other right and then now they said like
the doctor's typing into a terminal and
the patients on their smartphone and
that's how they're communicating
um let's go back to Aviation when you
and I are flying and you're landing at
Santa Monica Airport and you're flying
around in a Cessna you have to take your
eyes off of the outside world and reach
over and dial on a knob
VHF you know radio and then you have to
wait Peter because you might miss the
broadcast of the so-called no Tamp
system you might miss the weather coming
late so then you have to listen to the
whole two minute loop again now you're
flying you can't communicate with
anybody else and the plane should know
where you're going to land you're
generally frustrated just listening to
you describe what actually happens every
day forget about PGI just imagine there
was a an Alexa I actually changed the
name of my Alexa to so it won't go off
when I'm talking to you because I'll say
computer close the pod bay doors let's
see if it'll do it I changed the name of
it uh he's busy right now but anyway
imagine if we had a device and said it
knows we're coming up on Santa Monica
Airport let's tune in the the VOR let's
tune in the the uh the no Tam and then
Not only would it broadcast visually
because we can read things 60 times
faster than we can process auditorily
and it would just be a boot now why
isn't that available to Pilots right now
it's a it's a 29 unit right for God's
sakes well it's connected to worse than
that why do I have to use a human in the
loop at all right because when air
traffic control sends me my my uh Airway
vectors and so forth It's just uploaded
into the computer yeah and I should get
it and say accept and that's it instead
of it reading it to me me inputting it
reading it back them saying yes and it's
fraught with error uh propagation in
that regard and it's just question when
you're talking to an air traffic
controller no one else can use that
frequency it's not even like CDMA where
every other oh you're completely
blocking it which is actually a safety
risk too Peter right I mean some
terrorist right Aviation makes medicine
look Advanced which is which is funny
um so I think the humans are the
ultimate limit and but I do hope that
AGI will let us kind of segue out of a
world where we're dominated by you know
kind of the needs of catering to to
computers and using it more to cater to
what we actually need as an end user
this episode is brought to you by levels
one of the most important things that I
do to try and maintain my Peak vitality
and Longevity is to monitor my blood
glucose more importantly the foods that
I eat and how they Peak the glucose
levels in my blood now glucose is the
fuel that powers your brain it's really
important High prolonged levels of
glucose what's called hyperglycemia
leads to everything from heart disease
to alzheimer's to sexual dysfunction to
diabetes and it's not good the challenge
all of us are different all of us
respond to different foods in different
ways like for me if I eat bananas it
spikes my blood glucose if I eat grapes
it doesn't if I eat bread by itself I
get this prolonged spike in my blood
glucose levels but if I dip that bread
in olive oil it blunts it and these are
things that I've learned from wearing a
continuous glucose monitor and using the
levels app so levels is a company that
helps you in analyzing what's going on
in your body it's continuous monitoring
24 7. I wear it all the time really
helps me to stay on top of the food I
eat remain conscious of the food that I
eat and to understand which foods affect
me based upon my physiology and my
genetics you know on this podcast I only
recommend products and services that I
use that I use not only for myself but
my friends and my family that I think
are high quality and safe and really
impact a person's life so check it out
levels.link slash Peter we give you two
additional months of membership and it's
something that I think everyone should
be doing eventually this stuff is going
to be in your body on your body part of
our future of medicine today it's a
product that I think I'm going to be
using for the years ahead and hope
you'll consider as well so going back to
the question of are we saturating
um you know I I recently uh
gave a few presentations on AI and you
know this already and a lot of people
may not so the idea of artificial
intelligence has been discussed since
1956 right it was the conferences at
Dartmouth and so we're you know some 60
years later
and so why is why now why just now why
these last few years is it pivoting and
then you can say well it's because deep
learning is now a concept but you know
it turns out the first deep learning
algorithms actually were described and
conceived of in the mid 60s so 50 plus
years ago but what it is is four factors
as you know number one computation is
continuing to grow we're still on
Moore's Law we're still doubling compute
I just saw Steve germanson just put out
a graph that predicts through 2025 that
were just still on Moore's Law it's
still doubling every roughly 18 to 24
months
uh the second thing is the amount of
labeled data is doubling every year so
the amount of data that we're mining in
the world is just exploding the third
which was blew me away it was the uh
efficiency of the algorithms for
training large language models as has
been over five years it's been
compounding at 99.5 percent increase
efficiency and then finally it's amount
of capital flowing into the markets
right a huge amount of of capital
flowing into Ai and which bringing
people to it and then it's
self-referential right because better
coding algorithms are allowing you to
more rapidly code and experiment and
it's just it's accelerating it's not
slowing down
and so
um you know we've got Nvidia producing
more and more powerful compute
um than ever before so while certain
systems may be coming saturated and you
know we have these traditional s-curves
right where we have very low uh uh slow
growth and then a rapid period and then
whatever the medium is gets saturated
and falls off but the s-curves are
stacked and as you all know we have new
capabilities coming online so I think
what's interesting is going to be
Quantum computation coming online and
Quantum technologies that will support
Ai and machine learning algorithms
before the end of this decade yeah I
think you know one one kind of concept
I've been kicking around with but again
it's not my area of expertise which
allows me to you know speculate wildly
and enjoy that as we've as you know
there is this excess pleasure that
humans get from planning right
um is we need sort of you know and this
is now now mixing two kind controversial
opinions okay one uh one is that the the
existence of extraterrestrial
intelligence is limited to null and uh B
the existence of artificial intelligence
is wildly over uh over concerned or
people are wildly over concerned about
it now let's blend them together what is
the governing equation of the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence it's the
so-called Drake equation and I believe
we need a Drake equation for a
processing the threat or the risks or
the pro the prospects for truly you know
super touring level Ai and again it's
not my area of expertise but the one
thing I always teach my students and
actually I did this recently
as I'm teaching cosmology at a 45
brilliant undergraduates who will have
to listen to this podcast and leave a
thumbs up for you on your uh podcast
Network as well no that's how I grew my
subscribers so so violently those 45
students are important
they are they're they're really the best
in the known universe so I told them I
showed them the data from Edwin Hubble
now you would love to quote things that
happened 100 years ago and I have a list
of the the 22 things that happened in
2022 and you'll make your one for 2023.
as opposed to 1923 which I love seeing
so something happened in 1923 and it was
called uh it was called the discovery of
an extra an extra Galactic Nova in the
constellation Andromeda in the so-called
Andromeda galaxy was it true that we
believed there was only one Galaxy up
until then we believe we were it we
believe Einstein remember Einstein was
20 years before this in his special
relativity days up until general
relativity 1915. so we're talking about
1923 people did not know there were any
galaxies outside of the Milky Way in
fact the Andromeda galaxy Peter is the
most distant object a human eye can
perceive it's three million light years
away which means the light coming to us
left that particular Galaxy when Lucy
was walking upright in the Serengeti
Eddie planes it's just amazing to think
about right and you can see it with your
naked eye it's the only extra Galactic
thing you can see uh you know not
counting in the southern hemisphere you
can see the magellanic clouds but
they're basically satellites of the
Milky Way so when you think about the
fact that we didn't know until in Mount
Wilson in La Where You Are
that there was the existence of Anova
which is a oscillating brightness or
semi regular brightening uh star that
that can be used as a distance measuring
tool using tools that uh that uh earlier
astronomer named Henrietta love it had
come up with so that allowed us to
measure this up now we've only known
that the Universe had galaxies other
than the Milky Way for 100 years but we
didn't know the universe was expanding
and I showed the students the data that
were only taken in 1929 by Hubble's
associate vesto Slifer and other people
now you look at that data and the data
are horrible they're like scattered
around the y-axis is labeled wrong
instead of being units of velocity he
uses kilometers as units of velocity uh
distances but the worst part about it is
there's no error analysis each data
point is just put there as if God told
you you know there's no errors
associated with it whatsoever and
ironically of course he you know as I
joking misoverestimated the distance
which made the age of the universe seven
times too small so there were objects in
our galaxy which were known at that time
and their Earth too to be older than the
Milky Way galaxy it's like you found out
one day you're older than your mom it's
pretty embarrassing right and I don't
mean if your mom you know is your your
Dad's second wife or something I'm not
getting into that but if you think about
it we've only known that the universe is
expanding because of this kind of crude
data but that's very important I teach
the students never trust an equation or
a plot or a data that don't have error
bars my biggest beef with the Drake
equation in rest in peace Frank Drake
who passed away last year
um is that uh is that there are no error
bars associated with it so I did a talk
at the steady Institute up there in
Mountain View a couple years back uh
where I went through an exercise that
said how many people are visiting the
San Diego Zoo right now and it happened
to be this time of year spring break Etc
and you come up with a number and it's
about seven thousand and then if you
actually apply an error analysis an
error budget to each of the seven terms
that goes into that or the Drake
equation you get a number that could be
plus or minus ten thousand in other
words it could be negative it could be
people fleeing the San Diego Zoo and my
problem with with both the you know kind
of predictions and the catastrophizing
about AGI and extraterrestrial
intelligence we don't pay any attention
to the error analysis which is as a
scientist the most important aspect of
any scientific Endeavor fascinating yep
uh I I agree and it's I'm in the midst
of these conversations on uh
fear-mongering around AI my bias has
been that ai's most important tool that
humans are creating in order to help it
help Humanity solve the grand challenges
and there's been a lot of fear-mongering
from from Elon and from uh Bill Gates
and from a multitude of other
individuals now
I'm uh we have to look at what is the
basis for that fear and like you said we
can we can break it down and I don't
want to go dystopian in this
conversation but let's take one second
to go there right there is uh the
negative implications of loss of jobs uh
which is one category we can come back
to that and that will have real
implications and like I tweeted the
other day you know AI is not going to
replace you it's somebody else using AI
that will replace you right we're going
to have a uh we're gonna have a
astrophysicist co-pilot Brian for you
that's going to make your work far more
efficient and more rapidly publishable
and if you're not using it you know you
won't compete with your peers but of
course you will be and you'll be writing
the code as well to support that but so
job loss is one area the second area
that we can name is in fact the use of
AI by virus by negative forces in
society is at the same time that it
makes us more capable of solving
problems it enables people to cause
problems so that is a second part and
this this is where we get to on one side
of the equation which is AI without AGI
on the other side of the equation of of
AGI the first thing you bump into in my
mind is the terrible twos if you develop
a a truly artificial general
intelligence that doesn't know its own
strength and is trying to figure things
out and is exploring and playing could
it you know pick up the heavy object and
hit the glass table without knowing what
the implications of that are right so
the terrible twos the early adolescent
version of a AGI could be a problem
and then the extreme is a benevolent uh
malevolent AI that just you know is
Terminator and I I think that one is
frankly highly improbable I think uh the
version of you know AI for the movie Her
that is like you know we're bored with
you humans we're going off into the
Universe I don't think there's any
special resources we have on the planet
that Peter why do they have to get one
of the most attractive women in the
world to play a part where she's not
even featured in them I'm sorry my wife
is the second is the first most
attractive woman but
well done I'll take notes
um so you know I I don't believe in AI
is going to destroy us and is The
Terminator and I think you know our
Hollywood dystopian movies have just
gotten us our fear-mongering brain
activated way too much do I think that
AI could do things
um that are uh unfortunate and making
mistakes in its Early Learning possibly
I think I personally believe that
intelligence the greater the level of
intelligence the greater
it is in compassion and uh and love and
all the positive aspects I think that
the more intelligent people are the less
likely they are to be doing harm to each
other but I do think that in the early
days AGI is going to cause havoc in the
next uh election cycle 2024 is going to
be fascinating when a clone of your
mother's voice is asking you to you know
to vote for the other party no yeah and
it's really happening and there's
there's no sign of of it letting up the
you know deep fakes but yeah as you're
pointing out the shallow fakes you know
the less famous people and when you have
Shirley maclain is always you know
reincarnated as someone you know Ultra
famous like some Queen of Egypt or
whatever but they're never like oh I was
the you know wash basins you know
attendant in the 1920s jazz club yeah
nobody ever gets reincarnated like that
right uh but no it's it's you know we
worry about them you know deep faking
Elon and he tells you to buy Dogecoin or
whatever but it's really yeah you're
right it's the what is the level of
trust that we have on these on these
individuals and yeah your mom asking you
to do something is a lot is going to be
a lot more persuasive and they're gonna
be you know just as video game designers
and and casino designers and app
designers
um you know all kind of traffic in the
same milieu of human psychology in order
to generate outcomes that are beneficial
for their product or service I think
yeah you're absolutely right this is
going to be a tool that could be you
know potentially weaponized uh whether
you know you think the uses are benign
because it's for your favorite candidate
or not is irrelevant yeah
they're about to turn five so my boys
are 11. and you know I think about where
I was when I was 11 and as you go into
you know teen years and you go through
puberty and you know I'm you know one of
the concerns I have uh is the
implications of all of this technology
on pornography right and um that where
all of a sudden there are no limits you
know when I was growing up it was a
magazine but what happens when it
becomes uh
you know Unlimited in its capacity for
perversion and such I think they're
interesting unfortunate uh ramifications
that uh that unfortunately our
government is not even thinking about or
able to
uh able to contain and so we have a lot
of challenges ahead uh which have
nothing to do with killer Terminators
coming yeah and on the other end of the
bell curve you know it's it is of course
you know as a loving father it is very
concerning of me there are some tools to
block you know certain things for my
kids and I employ those and Chrome
extensions and I encourage people to do
that because simply I believe the most
you know people always say time is the
most precious research Source because
you can't make more time but Peter
really we waste a lot of time I mean it
is true I mean you you personally may
not but you know I know I do I'm burned
out at the end of the day I'll scroll
you know my YouTube feed and just watch
myself on repeat you know because I'm a
narcissist but they uh no I don't do
that that much yeah not that much but
but then I think about you know kind of
the other end of the Bell curvature the
seniors which have not only the same
kind of vulnerability and I didn't say
what I believe is the most impressious
commodity is innocence because innocence
and I've had on special operators on my
podcast I know you've worked very
closely with them as well I always ask
them you know like what what do you
regret like and and they'll tell me Dan
Holloway is a wonderful man and you
should talk to uh eventually and I've
had very close uh friends and relatives
that are special forces operators and
always say like I can't undo I can't
unsee what I did while I was in combat
and I can't undo it and thank God I did
it because they wouldn't be here Peter
they they risk life and death unlike me
you know fake doctor you know who's uh
you know it's just like risking getting
a chalk you know breaking in the middle
of lecture but but these are people who
have to have their innocence taken away
and you know and thank God in some sense
that they didn't succumb to not being
Innocent but kids have this innocence
that must be cherished and it must be
protected because it's a one-way ratchet
which can never go backwards and on the
other end of the bell curve are the
people that you just mentioned you know
which are the elderly which have real
political power they have capital and
and they're also vulnerable to this I
mean you think like I mean my twins have
have long known that if they want me to
shut up they just pretend they're
swiping my face you know they act like
I'm an iPad they can just change the
video but elderly you know they might
not be as as tech savvy as young people
are it's hard enough for me to keep up
with it so now they get imagine that
that combined with purchasing power
manipulation combined with purchasing
power that's really scary and I don't
see anybody addressing these ethical
implications I wonder what you think
about your friend Elon
and um and he is such a Mercurial and
interesting figure
um I wonder you know if you could kind
of you know convey what you think he
might answer to the following question
he's obviously a space geek he's a lover
of of not just you know going to Mars
and and as Martin reset you know Elon
wants to die on Mars I hope he doesn't
die on impact uh yeah uh but he's
willing to take these risks um which is
which is saying something because he is
a doting you know caring father he's got
10 kids I believe it's hard you know
yeah when you have poisson errors Peter
on a number of kids you're you're kind
of at the upper limit but but God love
him I mean he should and he should have
as many kids as as God or his mother
nature will provide but we have the
situation astronomy with with Star
Lincoln I have a starlink
um you know unit uh but it is it is
causing you know challenges for optical
astronomers but more so will cause
problems for microwave and radio
astronomers and he's talked and he's
engaged and it's true he has endeavored
to Black back in the satellites to make
them less visible but Peter as you know
I study the cosmic microwave background
radiation the thermal relic of the Big
Bang the most ancient photons in the
universe which just so happened to be in
the Ku band and Ka band and with uh
thousands of satellites darkening the
the sky there's no way to darken
something let me just tell you for those
that made it radiation there's no way to
darken thermal radiation it makes it
worse right
um so I wonder you know how does how do
you think he weighs these these Grand
challenges and it is almost ethical in a
sense like if you if he knew you
couldn't darken them optically and they
were just going to be glowing bright
with the you know Albers Paradox type
brightness what would what do you think
he would never think I I haven't had
this car I've had many conversations
with him I had
I had I spent hours with him last Sunday
at a friend's birthday party
um next time I'll ask but number one
he's doing what is legally allowed to be
done right so he applies for FCC
licenses to launch 30 000 satellites
maybe more he's gotten licenses to
launch you know on the order of ten
thousand plus
um
and I think
if I'm channeling my inner Elon he would
say the best place for these
observatories is not Earth orbit it's on
the other side of the moon
um it's going to be in in LaGrange
points it's going to be away from
Earth's radiation uh you know
transmission
and that we have a short period of time
during which we are burdened by by that
that in the you know we're going to be
back on the lunar surface in I don't
know three years time probably and uh
that started one of uh other graduates
of UCSD Dr Jessica Maier she may be the
first female to land on the Moon Yeah
well and I'm I'm thinking uh with
Starship going there uh uh probably
first delivering and and you know the
ability I mean Starship once it's up and
operational and we're recording this a
week before the presumed First Flight
launch attempt uh the week of April the
20th
um and we'll see uh I'm I'm hopefully
going to fly in
into a Boca Chica and uh Elon said his
goal for that mission is that it doesn't
blow up the launch pad uh I say okay
that's a that's a great goal and we'll
see how far it gets
um but if it does he'll say something
like ah it's just a scratch it'll buff
right up so cheerful when these billion
dollar machines explode but yeah uh
anyway so I think uh I think that
starlink has the potential to do
extraordinary good uh for Humanity we've
seen that in the Ukraine and it's a new
uh you know Communications layer wrapped
around the planet yeah it is causing
Havoc I'm surprised that all of this
wasn't debated by the FCC in granting
the license in the first place and by
the way it's a very Niche you know it's
how many uh there are more NBA players
than astrophysicists who study the
cosmic microwave background true
um but it is a window which once closed
can never be reopened and it's actually
worse than just the thermal radiation
which would be bad enough because
they're moving and they can't easily be
subtracted although we know their orbits
but it's the fact they transmit in the
band that we're looking at so they're
equivalent to millions of Kelvin uh
emission and we're trying to look for
Nano kill yeah yeah no it's impossible
it's it's like yeah
if if I mean what I would be doing as a
community is like saying okay Elon fine
but we want an observatory on The Far
Side of the Moon I've often thought
about that of of how to approach him and
he is a physicist and he did graduate
from you know a University of
Pennsylvania one of our close colleagues
on the Simon's Observatory the most
ambitious and most expensive Observatory
ever funded to do what we're doing it's
190 million dollar project by the time
it's done funded by Jim and Marilyn
Simons and the heising Simons Foundation
New York and and the Bay Area
respectively and what we're trying to
look for has such incredible
ramifications and I want to use this as
a jumping off point to maybe you know
not just for you to convey to Elon which
would be nice but that's not really why
I'm asking the second most famous
um in uh you know citizen of Lesbos was
a man by the name of Aristotle second
only to you Peter and uh
for clarity my parents were both born on
the island of Las Vegas and so on Lesbos
there's a lagoon and there's a wonderful
book called Aristotle's Lagoon and in it
is described the scientific method as as
understood by Aristotle and he talks
about some of the discoveries which in
the world of physics were almost
universally incorrect Peter uh he
believed heavier objects fell faster
than lighter ones he believed there are
only four elements he had a whole host
of of things that could have been
falsified easily falsified as Galileo
did uh 16 centuries later by just
answering a thought experiment by saying
well if heavy Things Fall faster than
light things what happens if I just tie
to light things together to make a heavy
thing shouldn't they fall faster at that
point of course they don't so that was
just a thought experience it didn't
require Like A Large Hadron Collider but
one of the things
um you uh that he brought up was and he
was correct about in The Natural
Sciences was uh was that whales were
mammals and it really wasn't understood
until Aristotle came up with that by
observing in the lagoons of Lesbos in
ancient Greece uh this fact which he
observed constructed a hypothesis did
more observations inductive reasoning
and then uh you know came up and
utilized this to for all the scientific
method we when you open your podcast
every week I listen to it you talk about
the massive transformative purpose and
you talk about what the uh what the goal
of the massive transformative purpose is
to create a dent in the universe unique
to the individual right
um we're at the point now Peter where we
are actually looking for dents in the
universe and it would be in the form of
a collision between universes in What's
called the Multiverse
yeah this is the most you know we we
have to as modern podcasters we have to
talk about at least two of the following
three things Bitcoin aliens The
Singularity or the Multiverse or also
we're living in a simulation exactly
that's right so uh so we'll we'll have
to defer some of those in the interest
of time like getting to the Multiverse
the Multiverse is perhaps the most
far-reaching and bizarre you know a
scientific hypothesis or Paradigm it's
not even really at the level of a a
hypothesis because it may or may not be
testable but one of the ways that you
could you could not falsify the
Multiverse but you could prove them
Multiverse so it's very unlike other
other scientific conjectures to whatever
extent you could prove something you
know I always say in the name of Isaac
Asimov who a great writer who influenced
the name of one of my kids I'll get let
you guess which one
he used to say if you think the Earth is
flat you're wrong if you think the Earth
is a sphere you're also wrong but you're
less wrong than if you think it's flat
right the Earth is slightly pear-shaped
it has a quadripolar distortion to it
because of its rotational act anyway
getting back to uh good old Aristotle
and and the search for for
falsifiability or quote-unquote proof
if we were to see the following
situation two universes that are each
expanding since their own Big Bangs
which could be wildly different uh ages
of their own Universe our universe can
exist for another 13 billion years
without changing too much prospects for
life and so forth
um they will eventually come into
contact let's say let's say they're one
light year away from us is Another
Universe and therefore that Universe
wants our universe expands into it or it
expands into us we'll have some combined
you know Venn diagram
intersection where these two things are
sharing some common sphere so imagine
two balloons are blowing up they're
right next to each other eventually they
hit each other
that is what I'm calling the dent in the
universe so what will happen is our
Another Universe will make a physical
Dent which can be perceived according to
my colleagues uh in astrophysics and
cosmology that you'd be able to detect
The Telltale imprint of the Multiverse
by the existence of these certain
patterns in the cosmic microwave
background that I study and those would
be unequivocal and you could actually
use that to motivate very high
confidence the Multiverse exists but is
if there is if there's an Infinity of
universes in the Multiverse because I
don't think you can say it's in is it
zero is it one or infinite it could be
it could be so there's multiple
multiverses of course right so there's a
Multiverse in time which is where the
universe expands and contracts and keeps
making more and more universes but
they're actually physically distinct in
space there's a Multiverse and this is
all you know kind of the numbering
scheme is courtesy of our mutual friend
Max tegmark at your alma mater and this
uh this this impact of the Multiverse
would be another distinct Universe
another level of the Multiverse and his
nomenclature or you know counting scheme
there's four different levels the the
Multiverse could be distinct universes
it could be one it could be an infinite
number or it could be a finite number
where that finite number is motivated by
something called the string landscape
which comes from certain properties of
the What's called the vacuum State and
phase space of different models of
string theory which is a number which is
effectively infinite as Max has pointed
out it's actually the number is finite
it's 10 to the 500th universe Max has
shown that once you get above 10 to the
80th which is you know no small number
either that you also effectively on an
infinite Universe where you'd have
infinite copies of or effectively
infinite copies of of events and people
and and so forth so you're right there
there are multiple levels one of which
is that there's an infinite number of
other universes and one where there's
almost infinite but I mean if that's the
case I would imagine that this
indentation uh would have been occurring
constantly all the time everywhere
unless they're at a phase in some phase
in some fashion or some or or in uh I
guess out of phase the other way I can
describe it well when you go to Texas in
a week or so you'll see you know the
gigafactory and so forth uh imagine you
bring with you a piece of sand two
pieces of sand from Santa Monica and you
put one at one end of the gigafactory
and you put another one at the other end
of the gigafactory those two grains of
sand relative to their size are closer
to one another than the two nearest
stars in the average vicinity of the uh
of the sun solar neighborhood in other
words space is unimaginably vast right
uh and that should stop you know people
to try to explore it and so forth to
colonize whatever but the uh but the
important fact to know is that it's very
large so so that when Milky Way galaxy
combines and forms milk dromeda when the
Andromeda galaxy which is only one of 12
galaxies Peter out of a hundred billion
to a trillion galaxies being discovered
by Webb and other instruments there's a
trillion galaxies say 12 of them are not
moving away from us it's spectacular
when you think about how rare it is that
we inhabit this universe but when one of
those 12 crashes into the Milky Way of
violent fervor nothing will happen if
there are people they won't even notice
the Stars will pass almost right through
them just like if you shot you know two
grains of sand past each other in the
gigafactory not a damn thing would
happen right so space is vast and and
with the universe and the Multiverse the
same arguments could apply there it may
be extremely rare that's why I said you
can't falsify you can't say the lack of
observation you could prove it yes
um I was curious I was gonna ask you the
question how many how many universes how
many galaxies do you hold in your mind
as the current number I mean I remember
sort of an average of 100 billion stars
per Galaxy and then it was like at one
point it was 100 billion galaxies in the
universe and then it was a trillion then
I heard as many as 20 trillion and I was
so where are you a couple of trillion is
the current estimate yeah it's all like
location location just like real estate
here in California one of the fun things
was I I remember Avogadro's number from
uh from chemistry yep 6.02 times 23rd
you know if you uh one estimate of the
number of galaxies and the number of
stars gives you Avogadro's number of
stars in the universe so I thought
that's right and people people then use
that to you know to make a claim of the
existence of life elsewhere in the
universe and we have to get to that
Peter because it's a mandatory in our
contract you know that we both signed to
have this product but let me just get
back we don't know how exactly how many
we don't even know how many stars there
are in the Milky Way galaxy let alone uh
how many galaxies there are total
outside of the Milky Way galaxy and so
we make approximations uh it also gives
you ever um has anyone ever given you a
star Peter in the international star
register yes I have earlier on in my
life when it first came out I think I
have a couple of those Stars it's an
interesting gimmick
um yeah what I wanted to just tell you
is that that you know speaking on behalf
of all you know professional astronomers
that's absolutely meaningless nobody
looks up so there's the the Amanda's HDE
2460. okay so but that doesn't stop me
from having the idea that now we can
sell universes in the Multiverse and so
I have the Keating if you go to my
website Peter Brian keating.com I will
let you buy me buy a universe for me in
the Multiverse but it's actually
seriously
I want to make an offer to your uh to
your listeners I have these chunks of of
rocks let me see if I can find one right
here I believe is one I don't know where
my kids have taken it yes no the
driveway battery sorry let me get uh let
me look around here it is okay so I have
chunks here Peter okay this is a chunk
of a four billion year old asteroid
that's a metallic chondroid looks like
it's a metallic chondroid right so it's
fell in Argentina in uh about 6 000
years ago it was discovered in the 1500s
and uh it was brought to Earth the
old-fashioned way by gravity but it if
you have a edu email address and you
sign up for my mailing list
briankating.com list you will
automatically win a fragment of this
meteorite because my massive
transformational purpose which I know
you're going to get to at some point
involves you know creating and
connecting millions of Minds in a
network to really bring free education
as you do so so wonderfully so I believe
education is the cinequa non of humanity
and what we do exquisitely well and
which doesn't actually need a university
and and don't tell Gavin Newsom my boss
you know but I would do the job I do for
free and I'm a public school employee so
I don't get paid all that much but but I
do what I do because I love it but I
also am under no illusions that a there
aren't better teachers than me that AI
won't supersede me if I you know I
recently translate or not translated
recorded the first ever audiobook by
Galileo with Frank wilcheck also of MIT
and and Carlo ravelli and others and and
this book I realized in doing has a
million words three characters it's it's
like a play Galilee was a phenomenal
writer you can get a copy also on my
website.com just to yep reinforcing
people's memory and so
um what we did is we took all that and
we just read it but I was like why don't
I put this into like some chat engine
this is two years ago now so I it really
wasn't as as prominent in my in my
frontal cortex but I realized you know
Peter I could be replaced by Galileo for
a lot of things but one thing I I uh
replaced by Galileo in the form of an AI
which is easy to do now
um and and the fact that nobody has done
that yet is is kind of giving me an
opportunity to do it but but the bottom
line is what I want to do is connect the
ability to educate people for free and I
think that will unlock because nothing's
more abundant than free digital
education I mean we can just you know
the 5Ds right we can just democratize it
and and demonetize it and that's what I
want to do so in particular the dot edu
folks I'm interested in reaching them
because the main obstacle I think to
higher education and the unlocking you
know Elon is not limited by money Peter
he's limited by brains
I mean he's limited by how many
engineers and and and so on so anyway I
want to scale this up I don't believe
that you need to go to a university even
a public one necessarily to get an
incredible education and trying to in
one way or another to make uh to
demonetize it as much as I can yeah and
if there's if there's two massive
disruptions that's occurring this decade
uh it will be education and health care
right uh covid was a tipping factor I
don't think we were going to see the
full implications of what occurred as a
result of the the shutdown uh for the
next you know five years but we're gonna
there is a massive reinvention of
education and a massive reinvention of
the healthcare Industries both of which
are unfortunately
um performing very poor per dollar uh
invested
okay now the single most important
conversation uh that one could have is
is there
life out there is their intelligent life
out there and we can talk about out
there being our solar system or our
galaxy or our universe welcome to the
great debate ladies and gentlemen on one
side of the story Brian Keating says no
we are the only ones out here we are
alone do not screw it up you know please
speaking of intelligent life
technological life yeah technological
life uh you're you're one dolphin
swimming through the you know the the
salt pools of of uh Titan that would not
count uh I believe that is possible but
I but I'm strictly speaking about
intelligent life I think that makes the
odds of me winning this debate much
higher okay um on the other side Peter
diamandis is no intelligent life is
ubiquitous in the universe it is a
forcing function that comes out of the
laws of physics it's reverse entropic
and it is something which uh we're just
beginning to understand all right uh you
know boxers take your Corners let the
bait let the debate begin we need a
neutral requirements into your younger
smarter and better looking than me
you're first all right Peter I've had uh
two like Peak experiences uh in my life
in terms of my career as a scientist
um one has involved launching Rockets
into space to look for the signatures of
first stars and shooting a night he miss
a lot of White Sands Missile Range and
getting clearances and so forth together
the other two you know Peak experience
is going to Chile uh 17 600 feet above
sea level in the Atacama Desert uh and
the other is going to the South Pole
Antarctica and all three of these
environments share something very
starkly similar and that is they have
the possibility for life in the deserts
of White Sands there is life and the
desert and the Atacama Desert there is
life and in Antarctica there there is
life and it is actually considered a
driest desert on Earth it's actually
drier than the Sahara by precipitable
water vapor content and it's also very
high it's a 9000 feet above sea level
I've gone there every time I go there
one of my kids asked me to bring back a
penguin you know because he likes when
you ever meet one of these people that
goes to a restaurant and they can't
decide between chicken or fish Peter
well if you eat a penguin a cut no he he
doesn't eat them he just loves them he
thinks they're the cutest things in the
world so uh there's a couple Penguins
there are a couple of giant like imagine
a seagull on steroids like just inflated
up like Jocko willing flying through the
air uh they're called scuba birds and
that's basically it there's no other you
know there's some seals and stuff that
come on the eye some orcas but then when
you get to the South Pole there's
nothing there there ain't nothing there
and in fact a hundred years ago 112
years ago humans made it there for the
first time and then it sat dormant for
50 years in other words we've not been
back to the Moon in longer than it took
for them to discover the South Pole
reach the South Pole and then for humans
to go back in the 50s and 60s uh only
took 40 years to do that we haven't been
back to the Moon in 50. let's hope that
changes at any rate my argument is is
connected to this calculation that you
did a few minutes ago which is you know
avocados number sometimes I call it a
guacamole because it's an avocados
number but uh 10 to the 23rd that's just
basically 10 to the 24th take a trillion
stars in each Galaxy trillion galaxies
nice round number now that's all fine
and good now imagine though that you
have just let's say there are eight
hurdles Peter that that life had to get
to to get to be technological and let's
call those hurdles you know first of all
there had to be on some particular
Planet an abiotic scenario unless we
believe that life came from the earth
which we know that the solar system
exchanges material so I will send your
dot edu listeners one of these
meteorites for sure I will not send them
the little tiny Fleck of Mars that I got
uh a long time ago also purchased
legally uh through proper channels not
you know collected by some Rover and
that flake of Mars meteorite cost more
than you know a 10 kilogram fragment of
these metallochondrites that I will send
to you anyway that came to us from Mars
the the more expensive one so that means
Mars and the Earth exchanged materials
and in fact you can buy if you if you
get a sample of the Moon Peter collected
by the Apollo Astronauts you will go to
jail for many many years as a felony if
you get one on eBay which I have
collected them you'll just you know give
them out but they're expensive the solar
system exchanges material back and forth
all the time which means not only can
stuff come to Earth from Mars stuff from
Earth carrying tardigrades or what have
you can go to Mars so first of all the
non-observation of life in our solar
system it has to count at some level for
the facility factor and I call it
facility Factor how probable with life
pre-existing to find a birth a place of
residence residing in the solar system
it is exquisitely low we don't know
exactly it's very difficult to quantify
it because as our friend Carl Sagan uh I
haven't had on the podcast but I had his
what is Widow and durian and his
daughter Sasha who are both most lovely
women I had the first mother-daughter
team ever in podcasting history in The
Sciences I believe anyway the um the the
you know as Carl Sagan said lack of
evidence is not evidence of lack or
somebody said that he could have said it
what I'm saying is let's say this
trillion trillion number let's say it's
up against the following odds there's
eight hurdles that life elsewhere in the
universe had to get to it had to go from
inorganic materials it had to go from
you know hydrocarbons uh had to go from
rather hydrogen than carbon and so forth
it had a form on a rocky planet perhaps
it may not have to be even carbon based
it could be silicon based Let's ignore
that you know we had whales as we
discussed earlier and that led to and we
had uh you know Prebiotic you know algae
and so forth that led to the existence
of oil and petroleum let's let's ignore
let's let's summarize let's say there
are eight factors like that there has to
be an outer planet like Jupiter to suck
up all the all the inbound asteroids
which this thing came from before it
impacted the Earth and sucked up the
real killer Planet uh planetesimals that
could have destroyed the Earth and all
life in it uh it has to have a moon not
too close to us and the tectonic
activity a spin rate a diurnal period uh
so there are very many properties that
have let's say there's eight of those
factors and let's say unlike what most
people you know believe that these each
individual term is incredibly improbable
let's describe it a pretty high
probability for each of the eight terms
let's call it 0.1 percent
so one part in a thousand let's say
there are eight of those what's you know
what happens if you take ten uh you know
you raise ten to the minus three to the
eighth power you get the same number ten
to the minus 24. okay so so that means
there'd be either zero or one other life
form in the known universe now again I
said before I hate when scientists don't
use error estimates the problem is how
do you estimate something that may have
occurred only once all the contingent
factors and that's just get to life let
alone that could be a dolphin as I said
swimming through a methane pond on Titan
uh which we don't see but um but now to
get to you know iPhones and and
technological life I just think the the
odds are incredibly low and as I said
I've been to Antarctica Antarctica you
know people will say well there's so
much room for stars and and life in the
universe and each play each star has 10
to the three planets or planetesimals
orbiting around it okay so you can
increase it to whatever you like but you
know Antarctica's one-seventh of the
continents of Earth and I've been to it
um and as I said just the mere
availability of real estate says nothing
about the probability for that real
estate to be inhabited so I turn it over
to you to decimate those arguments as
you see fit okay okay fair enough
um so first of all
we know that the building blocks of life
um the basic amino acids for even uh
even nucleotides that make up DNA are
present in the interstellar medium right
we have seen that we've observed that
through uh your colleagues in astronomy
so we can say that the the re the
prerequisite building blocks that could
lead to the early formation of Life are
out there
um and and for that reason any place
that has for liquid-based water life
that can that these materials can Reign
upon has a possibility of creating early
life forms right so our planet's four
point call it 4.5 billion and call the
universe
14.5 for round numbers for the moment so
um we believe life came into existence
on this planet about a billion years
after the Earth
roughly cooled and
um so
if we look at what the most I'm going to
be focusing on Advanced life if you look
at at what the highest atomic number
element that the human being needs to
survive I think it's iodine at around
atomic number 56. and if you look back
at when iodine probably came into
existence in our universe after a series
of of supernova
I remember I had this conversation with
with Dr William Fowler who was the one
of the great when the Nobel Prize for
Stellar Evolution it was his estimate
was about a billion years after the big
bang we would have had enough birth uh
you know death birth cycles of stars to
get iodine so let's assume that
um that life will have formed on planets
because I do think that any planet that
has
liquid water
and is within a decent radiation field
that the pre-ingredients of Life raining
on the surface will ultimately lead to
some single cell life form some
self-replicating life forms we've seen
the experiments over and over again
where you put these materials together
and they eventually lead towards that
process
so now the question becomes how many of
those
might have come into existence over the
last let's not say 10 billion years
let's say a billion years
and and how far has that come I mean the
argument that's typically made you know
fermi's Paradox is where are they right
if in fact they evolved
um where are they and
I had an experience which was uh which
was a centerpiece for me here I was with
my dad in Greece at a place called Mount
Athos which was a Observatory up in
another a a a a place of worship a
church up in the up in the mountains in
Greece and it was six o'clock and uh it
was time to call all the priests to
prayer and this old priest long white
beard long white hair black outfit very
typical walks up and there's this Bell
in the center and takes his Cane and he
he hits the Bell to call all of the
priests to prayer and in that moment
um my cell phone rings
and
I it it was like this cathartic moment
I'm like oh my God here is this Society
depending upon audio frequencies to
communicate with each other
and in that same moment little do they
know they're being bathed at 800 900
megahertz and 2.4 gigahertz frequencies
they just don't have the the tech to
perceive it or communicate
and so as we know the Drake equation one
of the elements of the Drake equation
which is the number of stars and the
percentage of stars that have planets
and the percentage of planets that are
in the right Goldilocks zone and the
percentage of those that form life and
ultimately it ends up with what
percentage of those life forms are make
it to a point where they're transmitting
in the radio frequency
and how long does that species survive
was the old dystopian point of view
um you know between the time they come
up with uh you know radio Marconi in the
late 1800s to the point where they blow
themselves up in a nuclear war that was
sort of like you know are they 100 years
old and I want to interpret that a
little bit differently which is I don't
know that the way we can and will be
communicating in 50 years
even involves radio frequencies anymore
is there a more fun I mean we would I
would imagine we know very little truly
about the extent of all the laws of
physics and there may be much more
energy efficient and
um and uh and and information efficient
mechanisms that once they're discovered
will flip a bit and all of this old
stuff goes away
um but the other side of the equation is
well is at some point
you know have they have these
intelligent life forms gone and built
starships and gone out and explored the
universe and if they have
where are they uh then my mind turns to
conversations like you know if a life
form that was much more intelligent it
could do Interstellar travel I'm sure
they could visit the planet and be
undetected I don't think that we would
be uh would be obviously
um you know in the scientific method
would have them come and observe us and
take samples and do everything without
disturbing us it's the prime directive
if you would of Star Trek
um
and then the question would be actually
at some point would we become uh digital
would we in fact not want to uh
physically maintain our bodies and go in
Starships would we upload ourselves
would we transform ourselves into a
technological intelligence that doesn't
need to go out and explore uh physically
so I mean these are the questions I have
uh that for me the probability in in
in all of these you know two trillion
galaxies and 100 billion stars that were
alone
um
you know it seems to me uh
a a false premise you know
we're you know here's the question I
think we're going to find out whether
life evolved independently we'll have a
few shots on goal on Mars in Europa
we'll find out when you look at its
whatever life form whatever coding it
uses is it identical we'll know whether
it came from Earth or not right we'll
know whether
um it it originated from you know
panspermia Theory where life has been
reigned upon the Earth and that's where
it started hey everybody this is Peter a
quick break from the episode I'm a firm
believer that science and technology and
how entrepreneurs can change the world
is the only real news out there worth
consuming I don't watch the crisis News
Network I call CNN or Fox and hear every
devastating piece of news on the planet
I spend my time training my neural net
the way I see the World by looking at
the incredible breakthroughs in science
and technology how entrepreneurs are
solving the world's Grand challenges
what the breakthroughs are in longevity
how exponential Technologies are
Transforming Our World so twice a week I
put out a Blog one blog is looking at
the future of longevity age reversal
biotech increasing your health span the
other blog looks at exponential
Technologies AI
3D printing synthetic biology AR VR
blockchain these Technologies are
transforming what you as an entrepreneur
can do if this is the kind of news you
want to learn about and shape your
neural Nets with go to demandis.com
backslash blog and learn more now back
to the episode yeah well you
see a lot of very you know I think
incontrovertible facts I mean one of the
things that we we talk about in space
exploration is we're looking for water
well I'll give you water you know that's
table Stakes water is made of the most
common element in the known universe
which is hydrogen and the sixth most
common element which is oxygen very easy
very stable I'll stipulate that it's
been found you know in the in craters on
the moon in ice form and obviously on
regions of Mars so water is not a
problem
even forming you know the precursors to
amino acids the problem is that uh and
and I'm glad you brought up Willie
Fowler who was a very close colleague of
two of my colleagues here at UC San
Diego Jeff and Margaret Burbage who
equally I believe deserved the Nobel
Prize but we won't get into the politics
of why that happened and Hoyle Hoyle too
Hoyle came up with the theory of
panspermia that you mentioned he also
came up with uh with the name the Big
Bang it was a really irascible character
I interviewed his best graduate student
giant narlikar who's still alive and
with us in Puna India but at any rate
all these precursors again
um it depends on how you do the error
analysis uh when you say I believe based
on this large number uh that that aliens
you know are there's alien technological
life okay that's incontrovertible but
you're using as a predicate the the kind
of phase space of available you know
objects that could nucleate form
habitable nucleation sites for primitive
life to form so first we have to
stipulate how how easy or hard it is for
that to happen and another colleague of
the burbages and Fowler was located here
his name is Harold Yuri and he's the
progenitor of the famous Miller Yuri
experiment which uh which when you go
through it is a very persuasive sounding
and many people have used it Neil
deGrasse Tyson you know this is the
experiment that lightning caused
energetic nucleation of uh
cellular forms of life yeah basically
you have you have a you have a a very
you know an oxygen vessel uh you put in
some phosphorus you put in some you know
nitrogen and stuff that was composed
they thought at the time of the early
Earth's atmosphere then you shock it now
comes some sludge which when you analyze
it has either some precursors to amino
acids or amino acids themselves but look
what went into that um uh and I'm not
even going to get into the theological
implications but you know they went down
to the chemistry stock room which is
located here in Yuri Hall and they got a
beautifully 99.9 you know five nines
pure or you know uh uh isopropyl alcohol
and they got this thing in that thing uh
sterilized reagent sterilized vessels
Bunsen burner at the exact right
temperature you know it's very different
than a stromatolite you know uh in in in
Australia very different and there was a
mind behind that right there are some
people and I'm not getting into
intelligent design I I have my own
challenges with that you can see me kind
of go off on people like James tour and
uh and um and also even on Steven C
Meyer who I consider a friend but but
the point is Peter that that a lot of
these things Trace back to premises
which depend very strongly on What's
called the Bayesian prior that you apply
so again if if you say the prior is how
many stars that could support how many
planets I can give you any number you
like but it's just like if I said
there's seven continents Peter so you
would expect a uniform prior for one
seventh of all intelligent life on Earth
to be in Antarctica when I go there
Peter I'm not even the smartest person
there I'm not even I'm I might be the
heavy easiest person there you know I
might be I might be the only native New
Yorker there I don't know there's only
200 people there you know uh it's bigger
than Texas but why wouldn't you
stipulate the same as at the at you know
at the bottom of the Marianas Trench or
at the top of the you know of the
troposphere I mean there are going to be
in a in a gradation of environments of
heat and uh and and energy food
densities and so forth places which are
ideal for life to form and places where
it's it's not ideal and I don't expect
there to be life uh intelligent life
across the entire planet
um
all it requires is there to be a single
nucleation point if the intelligent life
is then able to modify its environment
and then it's going to modify its
environment uh at where it takes the
least amount of energy to modify its
environment it's going to migrate if
it's intelligent to the places where it
can create food and shelter and
protection and so forth so the question
really is in the course of a period of
time is there a local or an absolute
Maxima or a local Maxima for that period
of time where intelligent life can form
and then maintain itself I think that's
really the conversation one argument
that people have used not original to me
is that you can't have Metallurgy in the
troposphere you can't have Metallurgy in
the Marianas Trench you can't get from
basic materials to the forget about
going from Prebiotic ooze to you know I
always say going from rocks to
Rachmaninoff or from you know bacteria
to Bach you know I have a million bad
jokes that's one of the benefits of
becoming a father right
um and so so but the point is uh I don't
believe I don't I don't have conviction
that just because it's so improbable for
technological life to exist in
throughout the universe that there is
none but I do believe almost to the fact
of
quasi-theological conviction not by you
Peter but but by many people in in the
seti game that this is it's it's almost
inevitable because the large number
hypothesis and that's exactly what Carl
Sagan meant when he wrote with andrewian
my past guest uh in contact that if
there is no uh other intelligent life in
the universe it's an awful waste of
space as Ellie arroway's dad told her
right so um and fun fact that's modeled
on a real person Jill Tarter who's uh
she's a wonderful guest you should have
her own
um but but the bottom line Peter is you
know there's there's no saying what a
waste of space is it's a teleological
implication and I think we need to have
a little bit of what Aristotle would
would kind of indulge us to have and and
beg our forbearance that you know there
there is a tendency to to extrapolate
from you know from sort of our own you
know maybe maybe you know kind of
pedestrian or or parochial observations
and say that these are Universal things
but I do think you're right that if
there are technological life forms they
may be computers they may be artificial
intelligences which can defy the laws of
physics that afflict us and namely that
they could travel at the speed of light
so uh so for all these reasons and and
believe me no one would be more uh
psyched and pumped for the existence of
extraterrestrial light as long as it
doesn't want to eat you know middle-aged
you know uh New Yorkers like me with a
little bit too much of Juan dupois
hydrocarbons I'm storing you know Peter
they say you should always have you know
six months of money and six months of
food on hand I keep the food on body at
all times
um but maybe you can help me with that
with your medical training but so I do
believe it's it's something which
dovetails back with where we started
which is that we need kind of a Drake
equation to assess the likelihood uh
where we assess the probabilities the
priors the uh Bayesian sense and taking
all the data and assess it maybe this is
something where AI can help us with once
they have their own kind of brand uh
equation for AI I think you're you're
right but I I also turn to a recent
example it wasn't too long ago that we
thought planets were scarce
um that in fact the best uh
astrophysicist astronomers uh uh
scientists in the field when you looked
at you know in the early days of the
Drake equation the percentage of stars
that had planets was seen was deemed to
be relatively low even though we live on
a solar system of
eight planets and one dwarf planet okay
fine I'll I'll go there
um but you know
we're finding planets everywhere now I
mean I all of the you know the
observatories we've launched is
disproving that we're also finding black
holes at the center of every Galaxy
we're finding galaxies all over the
place I mean whenever we have deemed
um to constrain uh these things uh we've
been wrong over and over again I mean
that's my observation of it maybe
there's the reverse which is that's true
and as we said earlier you know we
didn't know of any galaxies outside of
the Milky Way until less than 100 years
ago as you will include in your
newsletter this year and so it's a
startling testimony to how a brilliant
and and capable the human mind is but
but the the bottom you know kind of
under underlying fact is that I think we
have to say there is no evidence right
now it doesn't mean that there is no
existence but there's no evidence that
we have of anything remotely like that
and for that reason I think it's it's
almost
um it's because people is assume that
there is life I think it's important to
have maybe it's in my contrarian side
but to have you know kind of a counter
examples and and and and present things
because I think you know it's like these
people that make a bet that their
favorite sports team is going to lose
the big game and in San Diego that's no
that's no problem because we've never
won a major championship in any sport
whatsoever uh but uh but the bottom line
is uh no one would be more excited no
one would be more thrilled because from
these individuals or species or
artificial intelligences they have
survived they've gotten past the great
filter perhaps if there is one they've
also been able to master laws of physics
and laws of sociology and communication
and and so forth so I think a physicist
most of all would appreciate the
existence and that's why maybe I'm
hedging my bets and being a contrain but
I think I'm bolstered by the fact that
there are a great deal of hurdles to it
and and the final thing I'll say Peter
is
um you know do you care about your you
know 82nd you know grandchild to the
power two to the 80s you know do you
care about like 100 Generations a
thousand Generations as will mccaskill
talks about you know we're in the first
inning of a you know overtime or Extra
Innings game I mean I don't know the
names of my great great grandparents
right uh it's likely my great great
grandchildren won't know my name except
for you know if they tune into the most
popular podcast of all time into the
impossible uh so
um but I I like to think also we we've
explored the local area of the Galaxy
quite well and we've we've you know it's
true we've only dipped a thimble into
the ocean to use Jill tarter's metaphor
in searching the universe but let's say
there is life in another galaxy
it's three million light years away
Peter and I I think I think it's it's
almost you know it is becoming a branch
of philosophy at that point could they
be existing yeah but what really what do
you really care about just like you care
about your kids and your grandkids and
maybe their grandkids you know it's hard
to really think about well I really care
if there was a child living in M51 the
poster I have behind me the whirlpool
galaxy has 86 light years 86 million
light years away but there is
a huge philosophical religious
implications to the human absolute
Humanity right it is I think it's one of
the most one of the top two interesting
questions you could ask the other is you
know how did the universe come from a
non-universe how did life come from
non-life how did Consciousness come from
non-consciousness and then how did
technological life come from
non-technological I think those are the
four big bangs that are most interesting
to me and I love those and those are all
good sessions for us to have in the
future
um let me can I ask you one question to
wrap up I can ask you one question as
well do you want to go first absolutely
uh turnabout is fair play you want to go
first sure so as I ask my guests on on
moonshots and mindsets uh if I were to
fund an X prize for you uh the Keating X
prize uh uh what would it be what would
you want
uh innovators around the world uh using
their shower time in the morning their
sleep and and dream time at night to
solve what challenge what would they
have to build demonstrate make happen to
win the Brian Keating Express
is the monetary amount unlimited or is
it still 10 million dollars no it could
be 10 to 100 million dollars you know we
have launched 100 million dollar prize
and I was very happy Elon funded I've
got two more 100 million dollar prizes
that will be launched hopefully this
year
um so a lot coming but you know let's
put it in that decade yeah it's it's
hard and and I know I'm speaking from a
place of great privilege to say this but
you know we're we I am among the four or
five leaders of an experiment that's
close to 200 million dollars by the time
it's finished and that is kind of born
of conversations and visions of Jim
Simons and and myself and David spurgle
and my colleague Suzanne Staggs Mark
devil and Adrian Lee and this is to
really go back to the beginning of time
and understand whether or not there was
a a big bang we don't know Peter if the
Big Bang occurred once many times is
still occurring uh and so I think the
the James Webb Space Telescope has
disproven the bing bang over and over
again no that's all nonsense they've
they've learned much more than we ever
thought possible and they've built upon
what Hubble's been able to do uh but
there's no no sense that they've done
anything to do with the click bait type
headline suggests of disproving the Big
Bang but what I mean is we don't know if
it was a singularity we don't know if
the Big Bang occurred once not at all
perhaps uh the the big bang is a as a
misnomer as as Hoyle described it as a
euphemism for orgasm meant to disparage
and deride the theory that he called
atrocious because he believed in a
steady state universe well there are
modern incarnations of the steady state
universe and that's kind of what I have
dedicated my life to along with
this desire to bring you know basically
zero cost education uh to Consumers to
think scientifically I think that's the
greatest hope that Humanity has is to
really uh completely
um uh you know devalue the or
de-economic uh you know incentivize what
I do for a living so I'm undercutting My
Own Financial uh you know venal instinct
which is uh which is that I want
education at least in the stem fields to
basically be free and I want it to be
the equivalent of an you know we walk
around San Diego and and uh you know
thank God it's it's a very very healthy
economy down here but we have our share
of homelessness and my wife and I were
voyaging rounds and we found at least
the homeless have have cell phones okay
you can debate the policies that good or
bad and we whatever they have access to
information they have access to to to
data they can enrich and better their
lives Peter we need to do this at scale
and to make it really scale as you
pointed out to me when need to make it
almost free and it should be free it
doesn't it will be and there's lots
going on right now from the Khan Academy
in gpt4 and what you might mustak is
doing in uh in Malawi with providing
tablets and generative AI education
platforms for all the students there
but coming back to the Brian Keating X
prize
what would be what's the Grand Challenge
what's the problem you want to solve is
it an education is it in astronomy what
would you want teams doing building
creating here I think it would be to to
to cultivate uh an education a global
brain that would would then turn itself
using the power of imagination and
curiosity that I again contrarianly
think are unique to the human species
until proven otherwise I'm hoping to be
proven wrong but um but yes it would be
to to effectively to determine a way to
make a free University available 24 7
365.24 to every human being on Earth
because imagine that you know we had to
imagine that you know elon's parents
were they never met right imagine and I
know he's had great troubles with his
father I had trouble with my father but
but let's ignore that if you know
there's got to be more elons there
should be some illanas there should be
people the the world is vast and the 8
billion people that need to maintain our
ever burgeoning path to make a dent in
the universe as you say I think that
that can only occur with stem education
Peter I I I think that you can actually
learn English from learning science I
have a weird you know reading Galileo
reading Aristotle come on these are the
greatest Minds in history and and
reading you know of the Salam Stephen
Weinberg their incredible contributors
not just to science where they excelled
in one Nobel prizes or the equivalent
thereof but they have a gift for
communication as Feynman would say you
have to be able to explain it in simple
terms and as Einstein said but no
simpler so we have to get to this raise
the Baseline level of stem education and
that will allow us hopefully to Value
life to think of life as precious
preserve the the precious human capital
I believe every person is made in the
image of God and then protect the planet
which means to expand our Horizons
necessarily outside of Earth I think we
should save Earth beautiful all right
accept it now your question all right
your your question is the following and
I usually ask four of these questions
but I'm going to ask just one and it's
from our Sir Arthur C Clarke your old
friend I never got to meet him but uh
but uh Arthur said many things he said
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic he said for
every expert there is an equal and
opposite expert and he said the
following uh he said the following thing
as well he said when an elderly sorry
Peter when an elderly you're only like
two years older than me I think but an
elderly but distinguished you are very
distinguished when an elderly but
distinguished scientist says something
is possible he is very likely to be
right but when he says something is
impossible he's almost certainly wrong
Peter I want to ask you what have you
been wrong about you're the most
optimistic person cheerful person I
emulate you as best as I can when I
think of myself as being depressed I
said what would Peter do but I want to
ask you what have you been wrong about
what have you changed your mind about
that you thought was impossible but
really is possible
well so listen I I take
some extreme positions one of the
positions that I take is that we can
extend significantly extend the healthy
human lifespan or health span right that
we can break through what has been 120
year 122 year upper age limit
that there are species of Life on this
planet the bowhead whale that goes for
200 years the Greenland shark can go for
500 years and if they can go that long
why can't we it's either a hardware
problem or software problem and we're
going to be able to solve that problem
and that the tools to solve those
problems are
coming online this decade
so that's my belief which I believe is
probable
and you know could I be wrong there
possibly
um but I think it's a matter of time not
a matter of if
so I guess your question is what do I
think is impossible
um that uh I could be wrong about so you
know the challenge is I don't spend a
lot of time thinking about what's
impossible
um I think it's probably impossible for
uh
today's governments to deal with the
rate of technological change that will
be occurring in the next two decades as
we head towards Ray kurzweil's
Singularity I think that it's uh that
we're going to see governments failing
as a result of their inability to
maintain control and so that's going to
be interesting the question of whether
or not
they will be able to reinvent themselves
fast enough
to to stay viable as a government so
that's one element that I think of is
kind of impossible
um
anything you feel you've been wrong
about or you know oh I've been wrong
about time so I mean you know I started
an asteroid Mining Company uh a decade
ago and uh I remember having a
conversation with Elon about it and
saying hey would you buy liquid oxygen
if I brought it back from these
carbonation chondrites and he goes of
course I would but I think you're way
too early and he was right
um and I'll take another shot by the way
Jim Simons has an asteroid and I told
him about your asteroid Mining and he
said I have Mining rights on my
asteroids so he'll be interested too if
it does come around a couple billionaire
a couple billionaires in your corner
yeah well I think uh I think it will I
think we're we're going to see uh the
human species uh evolve off planet
um so one of the questions of course I
think about is is it uh planetary or
O'Neill you know Gerard K O'Neill a
friend a mentor at Princeton you know
advocated for creating colony in space
rotating space colonies that would house
on average 10 000 individuals that was a
wide enough genetic pool and a pool of
skills and that those colonies would
would Bud like like amoeba and you'd
rebuild and you'd you know go on an
exponential growth curve but rather than
get into the deep gravity well of Mars
and having to use energy to get off it
again so you know I'm much more of a
moon and O'Neill Colony guy than I am a
Mars guy
um so you know I might be wrong about
that maybe Mars is the place we need to
get ourselves to we'll we'll see I'm I'm
like really it's kind of
I'd rather colonize the moon and start
building you know with robots and AIS
O'Neill colonies out there uh in in not
you know dive back into the gravity well
so I mean that's another area of
interesting interesting debate
um
I don't know what else where else you
want to take it
well I think in the interest of time I
should wrap up because my young folks my
my twins are getting restless and
there's nothing worse than the terrible
the formidable fours as you know uh
Peter it's been a great Delight that's
always a pleasure to talk to you and
anything else you know that you'd like
to have my audience be aware of uh on
your side I'm going to have a link to
your newsletter which I get uh uh and
look forward to eagerly devouring every
time you write something I subscribe I
follow you on Twitter and elsewhere
anything else that uh would be of no
interesting for my my you know my
handles are at Peter diamandis on
Twitter and uh Instagram uh and
dmadness.com is my website you can learn
a lot more and of course moonshots and
mindsets
and Brian how about yourself where can
my listeners find you and and which
parts of of your life are the most
important for them to dive into
well I you know I just got one of your
final onboarding emails that said I'll
see you in the Multiverse and the
metaverse so I'll see you guys in the in
the Multiverse of Mines uh most places I
am as Dr Brian Keating Twitter Youtube
Instagram
Etc but the most important thing is is
really to connect especially the young
people uh I I wrote you know several
books one of which is called into the
impossible named after Arthur C Clarke's
phrase in this uh as well it's really a
self-help guide Peter of all I never
thought I'd write a self-help book for
my second book you endorsed my first
book which I I'm so grateful ever
grateful for and Julian Guthrie who
writes about you and her but she endures
my second book uh but um but I'm really
trying to really Reach the the the
undergraduate High School demographic
college and even graduate students and
postdocs and young faculty because
there's a crisis of loneliness and
isolation and imposter syndrome and I
talk about I open the book with my
friend who wrote the forward to the book
Barry barish up there in LA who won
prize for ligo discovering two black
holes crashing together at the speed of
light a billion light years away Peter
imagine that and I asked him like what
advice would you give to your former
self and he said don't have the Imposter
syndrome when you're 80 and I'm like you
can't possibly have the Imposter
syndrome you won the freaking Nobel
Prize and he said no no you got it wrong
when I won the Nobel Prize I got it
worse than ever because when you accept
the Nobel Prize which I'll never find
out about because my first book losing
the Nobel Prize which we'll talk about
some other time uh when when you win the
Nobel Prize you have to sign a lot a
ledger that says I got my check and I
got my 24 Karat golden medallion and I'm
a curious dude said Barry and he looked
through the pages and he saw Richard
Feynman he said oh my God Marie Curie oh
my God he saw Einstein same book as me
I'm not worthy I said Barry guess what I
have good news Einstein thought he was
unworthy and he said of who he said I
felt the Imposter syndrome when it came
to someone named Isaac Newton because
Isaac Newton did more according to
Einstein than any other human being for
western civilization and I said that's
not all Barry don't worry even Isaac
Newton had his own imposter syndrome he
said you got to be kidding me and I said
you know Barry you and I are both Jews
but there was a a man that Isaac Newton
worshiped and that was Jesus Christ
and I said he felt he never lived up to
in fact he felt his greatest
accomplishment was he died a virgin like
his his mentor Jesus Christ but he
failed in many other ways so Peter I
wrote a lot I do a lot go to my website
briancating.com sign up
if you have it.edu email address you'll
win a meteorite guaranteed if you don't
have one you're entered into a drawing
uh to win one of the first hundred
listeners of the podcast but Peter thank
you so much this has been a real honor
you've been so gracious
talk you helped me with my book and I
can't wait till we be together in person
like we were uh when I was writing the
book in 2016 with Sean Carroll who is no
longer in Los Angeles by the way well
buddy a pleasure and uh let's not uh
wait that many years again for our next
podcast be well great to talk to you bye
[Music]